قوه سائره في الاتساع بين قيادات طالبان
بدايتها كانت خطابات من وزير الداخليه
سراج الدين حقاني ينتقد فيها تزمت قرارات
قائد الحركه ملاهبه الله اخوا زاده بشكل
غير مباشر ولكن سرعان ما تحول الخطاب
المبهم الى تحرك واضح حقاني طرح فكره
انشاء مجلس شورى تناقش في اطاره السياسات
والقرارات بعيدا عن هيمنه قياده قندهار
جاء هذا بعد انقطعاد القيادات في كابول من
رفض اخوان زاده مقابلتهم ونقاشهم بخصوص
تعليم الفتيات وعمل النساء القرار الذي
وسع الهوه بين طالبان ودول العالم في
الوقت الذي تحتاج فيه افغانستان الى
المساعدات الدوليه لما تعانيه من فقر شديد
يكاد ان يصل بشعبها الى مجاعه قاتله
نظام اخوان زاد في الحلم شمولي حيث يتدخل
في الشؤون المدنيه والعسكريه على حد سواء
وهنا اتفق وزير الداخليه مع وزير الدفاع
ملا محمد يعقوب الذي يمتلك اهميه رمزيه
كونه ابن مؤسس الحركه الملا عمر هذا
الاتفاق يهدف الى محاوله التغيير السلمي
عبر مجلس الشورى ولكن في بلاد كافغانستان
لا تعرف ثقافه الحوار الا اذا كانت اصوات
المتحاورين ممتزجه باصوات اطلاق النار لا
يتوقع المراقبون ان تنجح سلميه التغيير
فهناك انباء عن قرب تنصيب رئيس جديد
للوزراء مقرب للقائد ومتشدد مثله هو قاضي
القضاه عبد الحكيم حقاني الامر الذي سيؤدي
الى تعزيز النهج المتزمت في تسيير
افغانستان انسنا ماسي
العربيه